hi I'm Andrea savage and I'm back one of
the few who've been back to answer the
internet if you had to get a lip tattoo
what would it say these lips I assume I
know what you meant
this well right now I have a new podcast
so I think it would have to say butthole
[Laughter]
what if I really had a lip tattoo bits
and buttholes I'm a mother if you could
get access to one person's phone and
look at all their [ __ ] who would it be
I think Ronan Farrow I feel like I feel
like as much as everybody tells me all
the things they put up their butts I
feel like everyone's telling Ronan
Farrow everything that's really gone
down is eating in bed gross
well let's see yeah I think eating in
bed is gross except I do eat some and I
feel like it depends what you're eating
like my mom serves her husband dinner in
bed as we've discussed on my show and
that weirds me out because she'll give
it'll be like a three-course meal so
that's strange but like if you're eating
some popcorn or like some snacks and
you're neat about it yeah all you owe me
on bad all you might want me on the bed
yeah yeah my point is I'm better than
you I hope that was clear what's the
worst possible way for someone to catch
you jerking off I mean I think all of
the ways are not right so let's start
there I guess it would be with them
going mommy I'm hungry are we gonna have
breakfast soon that would be the worst
can you still go to your barber if he is
very racist your hairstyle is not no
[ __ ] way no great
like my knowing where we get our hair
done if I went somewhere else you'd be
I'm fine if they're racist there's a
picture of somebody in a KKK outfit it's
like they're like are we doing now now
there's what's a woman I'm daring sexist
piece of [ __ ] um know if my if like
Heather suddenly was like well the thing
about white power that you don't always
consider no [ __ ] way
no there's an other people who can do my
hair would you rather be half your
height or double your weight half my
height if I went the other way you'd be
like Andrea Savage against little people
like there's my man yeah there's gonna
be a winner answer yeah if you could
have one person narrate or do your
play-by-play of you having sex who would
it be
god I think Jon Hamm just narrated my
journal entry from the day after I had
sex I feel like it's got to be ham he
kind of already did it so I feel like I
feel comfortable with him now in that
role alright the next question is the
Labatt Blue Light featured question of
the episode if you've made it this far
you probably don't need my instruction
but if you could pick any character from
TV or movies to be your college roommate
who would it be
these questions are hard I feel like the
first time I came it was like easy
questions that is hard to hear but
possibly right um any character from TV
or movies to your college roommate who
would it be
Oh let's go fleabag
it's it's it's everything and I'd be
thrilled which celebrity would you most
like to see in a sex tape I'd like to
see and even though she's a fantastic
actress I just like to see her in a
different light like a in the sex tape I
would go with I'm going hi Meryl Streep
because don't you think that Meryl
Streep's her sex making is elevated to a
different level than any of us are ready
to see or would expect I feel like
everything she does is just a step
better and I'd love to see that you like
it wait I don't think it would be
off-putting I think it would just
elevate it and be classier than your
usual art it would be an art okay would
you rather be a pig okay and be able to
orgasm for 30 minutes do they orgasm for
30 minutes
okay definitely orgasm for 30 minutes 60
times a day not interested I have things
to do and also Wow 30 minutes yeah knock
that out and then go along with the rest
of my day people meditate for 20 minutes
I'll do I'll orgasm for 30 minutes and
then I'll get go do drop off would you
rather be permanently hung over never be
able to drink again very easy never be
able to drink again
I hate being hungover and now I feel
like I get hungover after like two
drinks and it sucks and it's not worth
it if you could pick one country to run
what would it be us hey I feel like I'm
ready to take on the country I played
presidents out on Montez on veep I've
already taken the oath I've already been
sworn in I'm ready to serve what do you
think is the oldest someone's been when
they've had sex a hundred I feel like
how old's the oldest human that's been
recorded I want to say it's maybe like
around 100
1015 or something yeah but where we had
120 I feel like that's got to be I'm
gonna say around 100 if you found a porn
online of your buddy and his girlfriend
would you watch it I am not lying if my
buddy if it was like an acquaintance yes
but if it was a friend like if it was
Jason Mantzoukas no I don't want to see
that I don't think so and it was an it
with his girlfriend like it was like
someone that I knew was like their
intimate no I'm not interested I wish
that it was that easy I wish that like I
could just make there's an episode
there's an episode how much money would
it take for you to strangle a puppy I'll
tell you right now not enough money in
the world I don't I have enough money to
do what I need to do in my life and
you're not gonna I'm not saying I'm rich
but I have enough money to comfortably
not have to strangle a puppy that's the
level of wealth I have would you rather
everyone be naked all the time or
clothed all the time I don't know what
you like not that simple there's there's
there's nuance to it so you have to be
you have to have sex fully clothed like
going in the ocean fully clothed or just
everyone's naked all the time
100% clothes I don't want to see no
offense there's five people in this room
I'm not interested and then there's
three that I am so let's figure it out
you